well it's just what's extraordinary to
me is they they want to what they call
degender and neutralize language but
they're doing it from a completely false
pretext that you can somehow pretend
biology doesn't exist
particularly when it comes to someone's
sex I mean it's incontrovertible there's
no scientific doubt about this and yet a
small group of people have been quite
successful actually in reshaping
vast ways of the way Society talks and
is allowed to talk it's bullying and
we've seen the way
um JK Rowling has been bullied caffeine
stock has been bullied
um they've stood up to it but but um
it's very upsetting the way this tiny
minority of people has managed to
capture the discourse um to
um really talk aren't nonsense